ó ó
ora bem
é sim um pouco é nervosa porque acho que
todos os jogadores me roubaram as deixas
todas é importante vamos fazer
exatamente como eu vou fazer eu tive no
camarim
entretanto fazer ala lá não quero ver
não quero ver o vídeo faz de conta que
não ouviram nada hoje
ora bem quando o convidaram para vir
falar sobre esse tema é podiam ter
perguntado qual era o tema que eu iria
escolher e sem dúvida que eu ia escolher
o rio porque porque sempre me acompanhou
na minha vida porque eu trago aqui hoje
a minha bagagem emocional
o rio foi uma coisa que outro slide
durante toda a minha vida desde que sua
pequenina pra mim aceitar sobretudo
porque quando eu era pequenina tem é
feita mas havia um objeto que organizava
a escova porque toda a minha família
seria de mim porque todos correram atrás
de mim com uma escova de pentear e eu
toda bonitinha passado exatamente dois
segundos tinha este ar e portanto eu era
uma comédia na família e eu aprendi a
rir de mim porque mesmo apesar disso de
estar acima e despenteado e fica do lado
qualquer festa que eu fosse lá na frança
a festa de mi rosa 15 minutos de
escalada como estava tinha para aí 20 ou
25 mil da minha volta porque tinha muita
facilidade de fazer amigos e portanto eu
não vi o regime mas criou a rede também
comigo o que era ótimo
entretanto é limpar portugal e da frança
e teve algum tempo a viver uma prima que
também ela abalou aqui e te viverá
conosco há algum tempo e os pais ficaram
em frança e nós estamos aqui a falar dos
anos 80
e eu acho que ela era uma grande
visionário porque eu passei já viram
hoje é que provavelmente foi tirada de
vídeo do facebook eu já conhecia dos
anos 80 porque quase como todas as
pessoas da minha família e minha prima
não é uma pessoa é uma personagem e
raramente estava mal disposta mas quando
efetivamente e mauro spósito aborrecida
com alguma coisa da escola e dizer mas
quem fala nisso e ela não sabe vou
deixar que vou fazer uma terapia e
terapia da lei esta vez eu vou conseguir
de etapas em cima da cana olhar pro teto
e começava a aaa
estou muito melhor e portanto eu diria
que ela era uma visionária porque está
acho que agora se chama terapia do riso
geralmente faz em grupo mas podem tentar
sozinhos que resulta sem dúvida tem que
tirar acaba mal e portanto é entre
depois da minha infância adolescência e
sete com essa prima e um dia aparece
alguma coisa na minha vida que eu não
estava à espera um convite para uma
banda e de repente estávamos em todo o
lado mais uma vez teve que utilizar o
rir para mim é para mim aceitar porque
eu sempre disse que não tinha gostado
pode porque eu sou aquela pessoa que são
basicamente vergonha família porque
tropeça aí está sempre a fazer
chama as atenções sem querer e então
lembro por exemplo tem imensa história
de contarmos o tempo não seria
suficiente exemplo o caldo verde que é
uma das nossas maravilhas da gastronomia
é um perigoso inimigo para um artista
porque houve uma altura em que fomos
receber um prêmio talvez eu fosse
assistir à entrega do prêmio da ordem e
jantar não será um jantar de gala
comemos caldo verde e d&e depois seguiu
se uma pequena seção pessoas a conviver
e eu cheguei a casa toda contente e
distribuindo sorrisos e tenho estado
muito com as luzes por cima de mim e
chega à casa de opash ele o que eu vejo
uma curva nos dentes
eu estive provavelmente quatro horas
como acordo dentro e não houve uma alma
que foi capaz de dizer pelo menos muitos
devem ter rio
e pra mim é suficiente
outra também num concerto alguns fãs
conseguiram provar e todo o país
recebiam nós aguardávamos os carros que
era por trás do do palco eo filho com
certeza estava com pressa tenho ao meu
carro estávamos em lisboa e colher
marchê traia e quando eu cheguei quase
ao pé do meu carro estavam as gravações
estavam os fãs fim e tal e se que a
princesa diva
esgoto dae no meio do chão é minha irmã
uma corrida em vez de correr ajudar
muita preocupada não diretor rígida mas
a risa e eu no chão
comecei aqui também tanto que eu não
estava a conseguir levantar e aqui o
salvou porque dizer de ter sido a queda
do mito mas não é que eu passei toda a
raça mais bacanas e tauá são mais umas
engraçadas e portanto todo o meu
estrelato foi pautado por episódios
deste gênero e não vou contar mais
chegada porque pronto tem autoestima não
é entretanto é talvez das melhores
coisas que aconteceram na vida mas
também houve um episódio que foi sem
dúvida o pior da minha vida e o pior da
vida dos meus da minha família e dos
meus amigos e mais uma vez eu tive que
aprender a lidar com uma coisa que eu
não sabia o que acontecer a única arma
que eu tinha para me defender e
sobretudo para proteger a minha família
e foi o riso e eu queria antes de
começar o dólar dizer que eu vou eu vou
brincar com o meu cancro não com o
cancro certo e por que foi o que me
ajudou foi um a minha indicação foi uma
forma da minha família ver que eu não
sabia existir que eu estava a lutar e
portanto espero que tenham ambiente um
pouco aberta e não sentia isso como uma
uma brincadeira sobre o cancro ou o ou
as suas consequências
eu posso brincar com o meu cancro então
das primeiras coisas que também
aconteceram foi pensar ou cair
as pessoas eu fui à média que desagrava
e ea médica utilizou agora tenho nada
pra ela não lembrar algumas pessoas que
minha amiga que é muito sincera comigo e
me disse uma vez em muitos anos que
usava um capacete e ela dizia mas sim
mas eu tenho namorada e umas 20 anos ela
vive ea gira-gira magia aquilo é
diferente e essa média a mesma técnica
perguntei a grave é mas tem alguma
hipótese é grave
pronto é basicamente via andaraí 1 por
cento
mas o que eu fiz foi agarrar e enquanto
isso agora no livro cantor saber em
primeira mão
no livro que vou editar agora é só
pensar no livro lugares não portanto o
que eu digo meu livro é que porque não
nos agarramos de 1%
quem sabe e o fato é que contra todos os
prognósticos
eu aqui estou e provavelmente também
porque eu acho que quanto a morte de
caro mas é provavelmente foi o que
aconteceu
então estávamos nós com o prognóstico
que estava grávida tive que adotar e etc
foi mesmo o cenário péssimo e e depois
prendia-se tanto nos treinamentos quanto
antes e havia aquela coisa de time cair
o cabelo como é que eu vou reagir a isso
e mais uma vez que eu fiz e então para
me sentir à vontade primeiro cortei o
cabelo como o rapaz estava pavoroso
persistir um morto em cima da cabeça
então o replay não ficou mal mas depois
anterior o mesmo todo sobrancelhas
externas etc
e como é que eu ia aceitar aquela visão
foi muito simples comprando uma peruca e
quando eu lhe digo nem precisa dizer
quer dizer é pavoroso da barriga ea
partir daí eu pensei não quer lenço no
cabelo ea testa a mim o meu crânio e
anahí não sai grupo a não sair e imitam
melhor ea partir daí foi um sorriso
piadas
imagina eu ea minha mãe sempre presente
pra fazer um e as notícias e os bandidos
deste homem e os homens deviam ter
trabalhar e sofrer e saber o que a mesa
ea minha mãe que é uma certa pessoa
disse a filha não tem fantasias que deus
castiga exigia se vai manter o cabelo
depois a havia uma barragem muito
grandes a cobrar que era os meus amigos
quando temos alguém perto nós com uma
doença muito grave
temos tendência a afastar nós porque não
sabemos o que dizer não saber nos olhar
sem ter pena
gostamos dessa pessoa e eu tinha que
quebrar essas barreiras porque eu
precisava dos meus amigos e precisava da
rede
não tem mal nenhum em ter um cancro e
reader e então é contigo uma pausa tive
praticamente três anos no iptu
mas quem algumas pausas minha casa e
tive duas amigas curiosas
e eu fui
i é é é normal ela tinha muitas dúvidas
num muitas coisas do tipo dias saíram
num sítio público e disse vou ter
conversas ao café ea fome sem ter na
mesa e elas a eu quero um café e tu e eu
também nunca feche as portas e os
impostos não há problema quanto e
olhavam para mim e estava ali um apesar
de perceber eu preciso de bloqueador de
conversa e comercial negócio de vocês
mas na verdade é preciso ajuda na altura
tinha se todos sabem o que é um cateter
que é uma para o draft sina que se
insere na pele e vai e portanto enfiar
dentro de uma vaia
depois tem dois tubinhos é sair e uma
torneirinha basicamente concordámos em
que são serviços e aqui estava guardada
dentro da minha roupa pois tinha que ser
tranqüila e produtiva e então a
conversão da linha o lado e eu percebo
que aristide se olha tem que me ajudar
eu poder poder perca a fé posso pedir
ajuda e que até teria que ser assim
poderiam ser atualizada ea partir daí
maravilhoso foi uma uma conversa
espetacular e foi engraçado porque ponto
voltou ao normal às minhas amigas com as
mesmas perguntas é lá que tu achas
depilação que acha ser a arena de pensão
e lesariam eu sei nada melhor do que mel
e radioterapia é que não escapa um não
há só por ver os jogos
e produtivo que então é lidar com a
doença infelizmente como vocês vêem o
praia abre a doença e agora sei do ip
office médico está estável mas estou
solteira e portanto é estou no mercado é
mais uma vez tem que aprender a lidar
com isso porque é o único grande
tragédia e agora sou eu e os homens
porque imagine o seguinte cenário
estou num sítio público após o número 43
chega sanfona permite smola eu sou o tal
e eu pra mim o que faz e eu quanto
técnica lado volta ao mundo suas coisas
e tentam refazer a eu sou engenheiro
aeronáutico e ponte e vive uma vida
saudável e bem aqui estou sentindo o
clima mas vai sempre o raio da pergunta
e tu o que fase já não há maneira de dar
a volta e eu digo eu estou formada porém
vale tem esse está foi o hands u
não tenho qualquer problema com isso
precisava e não tenho eu revi vencido
não faz cristo tv
é preciso sair
obrigada por ano e ajudarem a aliviar a
aliviar aqui a minha bagagem emocional e
esse não esquece o meu cancro é não vou
lamentar o resto da minha vida como é
óbvio mas aconteceu
mas tem que ter em atenção que há coisas
que eu tenho que respeitar porque eu fiz
um transplante de medula e por tanto
tempo pra cá ver agora como vou juntar
aí eu vou ser suplantada e aproveita os
outros oradores
isso é uma coisa que eu já tive para que
sabia é que o riso é contagioso
obrigada
ó